I waited a long time out in the world
before I gave myself permission to fail
do you need a time in your life right
after college to suffer a little bit to
keep you on your toes I think it's not
so good to live in the past or have the
clarity of the past I'm guilty of being
a jewel hello believe nation I'm Evan
Carmichael my one word is believe and I
believe that entrepreneurs are going to
solve all of the major problems of the
world so to help you on your journey
today we're going to learn from Game of
Thrones actor Peter Dinklage and my take
on its top ten rules for success rule
number one is my personal favorite and
I'd love to know which one you guys like
the best and as always guys if you're
watching if you hear something that
really resonates with you please leave
it down in the comments below put quotes
around it so other people can be
inspired and when you write it down it's
much more likely to stick for yourself
as well enjoy
when I was 29 I told myself the next
acting job I get no matter what it pays
I will from now on for better or worse
be a working actor so I quit my position
at the professional examination services
my friends really weren't happy about
that because he was so easy to find me
when I worked there work though was the
only place I had the Internet this was
at the beginning of the Internet and now
I didn't have either the internet or a
cell phone for a job but something good
happened
I got a low-paying theater job in a play
called imperfect love which led to a
film called 13 moons with the same
writer which led to other roles which
led to other roles and I've worked as an
actor ever since
[Applause]
but I didn't know that would happen at
29 walking away from data processing I
was terrified ten years in a place
without heat six years at a job I felt
stuck in maybe I was afraid of change
are you my parents didn't have much
money but they struggled to send me to
the best schools and one of the most
important things they did for me and
graduates maybe you don't want to hear
this is that once I graduated I was on
my own
financially it was my turn
[Applause]
parents are applauding graduates or not
[Applause]
but this made me very hungry literally I
couldn't be lazy now I'm totally lazy
but back then I couldn't be
and so at 29 and a very long last I was
in the company of the actors and writers
and directors I'd sought out that first
year that first day after school I was I
am by their sides raised the rest of
your life to meet you don't search for
defining moments because they will never
come the world might say you are not
allowed to yet I waited a long time out
in the world before I gave myself
permission to fail please don't even
bother asking don't bother telling the
world you are ready show it do it what
did Beckett say ever tried ever failed
no matter
try again fail again fail better I'm a
writer so I'm kind of curious what type
of scripts do you get coming your way
that you're tired of originality at I
know that's a very but without it being
aware that it's being original a lot of
scripts are trying to be very original
and that they're so self-aware I think
we're living nowadays in a meta Society
and we can't help ourselves on that and
I think a lot of manifest a lot and
scripts that I read
like their Charlie Kaufman for example
he came into this world and he wrote
those movies and since charlie people
have tried to be like Charlie's movies
you know they've sort of followed try to
follow that form but it's not the road
it's Charlie's and so sort of follow
your own take your own path right what's
true to you and no one else and then it
will be wholly original that's what I
look for when you grow older you moved
to Brooklyn and and then in those days
Brooklyn was Brooklyn it's yeah
different now Williamsburg yeah in the
early night was your life like over
there the terrible real yeah well I
think it you need a time in your life
right after college to suffer a little
bit to keep you on your toes but I
remember I had this apartment that
didn't have any heat none of them had
ever had any luck then we put up plastic
on the on the windows in the winter sort
of like in here yeah I want to go into
the future I think this I don't know if
I would use this machine or relieve any
memories I think it sort of can be
destructive that's my takeaway from this
I know my I would yeah reducing machine
yeah oh yeah yeah I'm with you
with yeah that's interesting yeah would
you use it I think it's not so good to
live in the past or have the clarity of
the past we should romantic eyes it
that's what we do storytelling but Peter
this is the last season at schema
Thrones like there's nothing you would
miss or you have favorite memory of that
I got to move on we've got to move on
moving that's all moving on it's all
about moving on your people taking
pictures especially please like this
they just they want the proof
memory that they'll actually experience
and something to remember a sort of
strange kinder picture and they don't
really meet you or that's is the sort of
thing that's happening now it's
replacing an experience or memory that
you will have instead of just a memory
before I'm sure you start to apply your
own memory to that photo and miss and
and changed events and how they went
down what is the most important lesson
that you have learned in your course as
professionals I think with the culture
we live in today the internet and web
Bitton things and the Twitter and the
gobbler and the bubble you know I think
part of the reason why Marlon Brando is
who Marlon Brando was why he was one of
the probably yes to me the greatest
actor ever because we didn't really know
too much about him when he was younger
and that left it very mysterious so we
were able to get lost in his characters
more but nowadays the bit there's so
much knowledge of everybody's personal
life that you sort of can't get lost in
the characters they play so my my
professional thing that I've is just to
shut up and the less is more happen
again we find that we have an innermost
Randall but going back to basics because
today people complain that we have been
insulated for too long by digital
technology too many special effects we
want to you know have more real human
characters in the movie what do you
think well yeah I mean what I I just I
kind of don't understand
I mean films from the far east have
always done it that I've seen why can't
a an action movie also be very
heartbreaking and personal why can't a a
horror film be very dramatic I feel like
in some times in America we get trapped
by our genres and we don't overlap and I
think that's unfortunate and something
like this which has such science-fiction
elements to it also is a very deeply
personal film for a lot of these
characters and very dramatic and very
sad and heartbreaking you get very
emotional watching a film like this and
you sort of forget that you're watching
a big summer blockbuster film I think it
I find it kind of sad that that's so
much surprising because the writing has
gotten so sort of formulaic especially I
think sorry in television but you just
got to push the envelope and challenge
people's expectations and ideas of
what's happened going to happen next and
I think we do that and I think that adds
to the addiction of the show you never
know what's around the corner
well she's do you suppose um all the
words mean that this that people are
it's just great it's another word that
you know people love what you did and
that's always means well it means good
actors I think need a lot of
confirmation for what they do I think
that's why we have all these awards says
it says it's just a movie we made for no
money
in 20 days and it just feels good to get
recognized or something like that
you know we made the movie for half a
million dollars and then we struggled to
get it made and it's just it's found an
audience which we didn't know was going
to find you know it's very personal
movie Tom McCarthy the writer director
is his first film and he wrote as to the
three lead actors and and then Miramax
bought the film at Sundance about a year
and a half ago so think it's a crazy
ride I saved you
I saved this city and all your worthless
life I should have let Stannis kill you
all here do you wish to confirm yes
Father
I'm guilty guilty is that what you want
to hear you admit you poisoned the king
no of that I'm innocent I'm guilty of a
far more monstrous crime I'm guilty of
being a dwarf you're not on trial for
being a dwarf oh I've been on trial too
that my entire life have you nothing to
say in your defense
nothing but this I did not do it I did
not kill Joffrey but I wish that I had
watching your vicious bastard die gave
me more relief than a thousand lying
[ __ ]
I wish I was the monster you think I am
I wish I had enough poison for the whole
pack of you I would gladly give my life
to what you ain't swallowing the man
[Applause]
I will not give my life for Joffrey's
murder and I know I'll get no justice
here I will let the gods decide my fate
I demand a trial by combat
[Music]
[Applause]
you
thank you guys so much for watching I
made this video because Roderick asked
me to so there's a famous entrepreneur
that you want me to profile next check
out the link in the description and go
and cast your vote I also want to give a
quick Charlotte to Imran Dean everyone
thank you so much for picking up a copy
of my book your one word and posting
that awesome picture on Instagram I
really really appreciate the support and
I'm glad that you enjoyed the read so
thank you guys again for watching I
believe in you I hope you continue to
believe in yourself and whatever your
one word is much love easy
your career when I look at some
we've had in the past the breakout world
people described as being in the Moody
the station agent while back even a
big-budget film like Elsa where you
played a very sort of a pugnacious and
children's publisher if that is accurate
description it seems like you've managed
to find the roles that upend
whatever those stereotypes might be yeah
well I try to you know and that's I'm
not really successful at it you do have
to make a living and I do not fault
anyone else who who makes choices to
play characters that they wish they
hadn't agreed to do and because it at
the end of the day none of us are happy
with our jobs all the time but I just
sort of had some perseverance in terms
of what I wanted to do and what I didn't
want to do and I think know is a very
powerful word in our business that is
very hard to use early on in your career
but I also think I was pretty arrogant
when I was younger so I used that word
maybe too much but it also helped me
with finding roles that I did like what
was the first time you stood on stage
and thought I want to act and this is
the only thing I want to do oh I just so
many years ago I didn't remember oh
you're a baby give me a break
oh I think a lot of us are just little
hams no more children and it just starts
that way but you know my mom's the music
school teacher and kids would come in it
was a revolving door policy at our house
growing up in New Jersey where piano
lessons were given all day throughout
the day and my brother and I would be
putting on puppet shows down in the
basement and constructing these
elaborate sets and putting on these
shows for all the octogenarians of the
neighborhood
and they were kind enough to pay a
nickel so the arts would sort of this
was something in your background it just
came at an early age yeah I don't know
but when it starts with when you trace
it back to when you're a little child
you can't really remember this big
moment I think it's a lot of little
moments that build up into something
that just forms who you are and your
need to be an actor
can you just catch me up on what's
happened so far and first few seasons of
Game of Thrones what we have a minute
about 45 seconds now stabby stabby
stabby study sexy sexy sexy savvy savvy
savvy beautiful beautiful language and
beautiful scenes of poetry and musing on
the world that lead as we know it in
King's Landing and then a couple jokes
more stabby stabby oh you sure can
brother sister whoo is that what that
means it's a list I wanna be 40 if
you've already flop they're going look
at my fingers in a circle look at that
good mmm